hello everyone today I just wanted to
show you how to navigate expression
tables how to download the files from
your RNA seek pipeline and then how to
use that those files to normalize them
and then run factor regression analysis
so let's take a look this should be your
pipeline so you probably ran something
like our sim or maybe you did
differential gene expression and then
this is your output file so you have
your d set files and you can download
the zip file and then inside you will
see the D SEC files that you can look at
full change in the P values and then
over here you have expression genes fpkm
now that is the table that you want to
use you can use this table for principal
component analysis you can use it for
normalization you can use it for other
machine learning methods and you can
also use it for the factor regression
analysis now before you go on you
actually have to normalize the table so
here's my normalization table you
actually do start quintile normalization
and ends just the same way as you did it
for PCA so remember that after quintile
normalization you can also do PCA in
this utilities section and then you will
get this kind of a file again make sure
that this is a txt file and this is gene
expression values and SP km so what does
this table look like so this table
actually looks like this this table will
have a gene ID again the same way that
we looked at the expression genes and
then it has values inside but your table
is going to have a lot more samples over
here because we started off with a bunch
of samples from all the breast cancer
files but to do factor with Resha
analysis we're going to do something
different we're actually going to select
those samples that have two types of
cancer and estrogen receptor-positive
and triple negative and two types of
mice nod
and a fee McNew so these are the two
mice types that we can compare and the
two cancer types that we can compare in
terms of soccer relationship and in
terms of interaction of faculties so
this table is going to be available in
the lesson you can download it as well
or you can just take your expression
table and then you can download you can
delete the files that are not fitting
this description now how did I select
these specific samples let's take a look
so in the supplementary files with that
come with the publication there is this
description description for each one of
the runs what type of a mouse so you can
see that there is Sid non-skid gama
authentic nude etc and then if we want
to take you know the ones that we can
compare let's we can get rid of this one
and this one and this one or sorry me
this one so we will have a smaller
number of samples and then over here we
have hormone status so we have ER
positive and triple negative so how do
we select samples so we list all of our
samples that have the same combinations
and then we'll just select two of each
one two of each combination so we will
have four pairs 4 times 2 is going to be
8 so 8 samples and here is the ones that
we selected so triple negative skid
triple negative skid triple negative
etheric new triple negative of thing and
then ER at the include er I think noon
and ER skid your skin so these are the
ones that we selected so there's going
to be 8 files so let's take a look at
our table there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 files
and what I did was I deleted all the
long names that we had with the group 1
and group 2 because a long name is
actually going to break the
the algorithm it only reads so many
characters so we shortened the name and
now we have a clear indication over here
for what the file name is and then what
group it should belong to okay so now we
can go back and we can go to areas of
analysis and this is now how to run Zack
the regression analysis right so we can
go to supervised analysis why supervised
because we know what we already
annotated these samples so that's based
on annotation so therefore it's
supervised now we can do start and then
we can select factor regression analysis
now after you do that you get this
little pop-up and you can create how
many factors and how many levels within
each factor we are going to work with so
we have two factors Mouse type and
cancer type right so we will add one and
how many levels within each one we have
two so we have P are positive and triple
negative that's two factors for cancer
so type two and how many mice do we have
we have two types of mice non and ethnic
new so let's put two over here as well
and let's do next now we can add our
file so now I have prepared this in a
txt format now you can notice that I did
too I have the original one and then I
also ran quantile normalization with
threshold of five so I'm going to upload
this so you see a hundred percent check
and now I have so let's take a look at
what we have ER nod er nod er epidemic
nude er at the net nude triple negative
non triple negative non triple negative
within a new triple negative
estrangement so how am I going to
separate this so what is a 1 a 1 is
going to be er not so I'm gonna put okay
so sorry a 1 is er v1 is not so I'm
put these two here what is a 1 B 2 a 1
is a Arnaud or sorry er er is our first
factor is cancer type and number one is
er but second factor for the type of
mouse so that is going to be at the
McNew I'm going to put this one and this
one and the same thing for the second
type of cancer triple negative we're
gonna put triple negative so you can see
that nod nod is here in ER triple
negative and then at Simmons nude that's
in acute that's it
now I continue and okay and now I'm
going to save my pipeline and give it a
name that I can remember what I'm doing
so what did I do
I took PD X and then I quintile
normalized it and then I'm doing a
factor analysis okay I'm gonna save this
run my pipeline and make sure that you
run the pipeline and you see that it
started okay and what you will see is
these are actually quite fast pipeline
so it's not going to take a long time
but I'm gonna just show you that output
they are I already have so this is what
it's going to look like
okay and this is what the output will
look like after factor regression
analysis so again we do have the gene ID
and then over here in each one of these
columns you will see what the file name
was so up until over here this is
exactly the same and then here you have
the factor analysis results of these
columns so this is t-test F test for the
combinations of sample of factors and
levels and the rest of us you can follow
through the transcriptomics to lesson to
work with this table and I will prepare
another video so that we can also review
that just like this